et bien bonjour à tous tout d'abord je
suis désolée qu'en cette période de
communes nous puissions pas être
ensemble
donc je vais vous présenter quand même
en faisant semblant que vous soyez tous
là on a besoin de ça donc aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler de l'ia entre rêves
espoir et réalité il ya eu beaucoup
d'espoir il ya beaucoup d'espoir sur le
sur l'ia il ya beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes sur l'île il ya aussi des
choses qui n'ont pas marché donc
beaucoup d'espoir sur l'ia en
particulier dans cette période de coheed
cependant des études ont montré à
travers iwai que les l'indisponibilité
des données pertinentes au niveau du col
vide n'a pas permis à l'ia d'apporter
des réponses satisfaisantes et d'aider
suffisamment caisse pourquoi pourquoi ça
on peut se poser la question et c'est
intéressant de d'étudier cet aspect là
on sait que l'intelligence artificielle
est potentiellement apporte énormément
de choses mais pourquoi sur le co vite
ça va rien apporter
alors en fait on a la technique on a la
puissance
on a tout ce qu'il faut par exemple nos
smartphones 70 mille fois plus puissant
que l'ordinateur d'apollo 11
donc c'est quand même énorme cette
puissance et ça on parle que d'un
smartphone pour autant on n'avait pas
les données pour apprendre pourquoi on
n'avait pas les données c'est plutôt
simple c'est qu'en fait si vous prenez
des hôpitaux qui était dans le rush dans
le premier confinement mais qui vont
continuer de l'être ensuite essayé de
d'organiser quelque chose autour de la
récupération des informations autour des
patients comprendre quels médicaments
donne quels résultats dans quelle
thérapie et suivre les thérapies etc
c'était quelque chose qui n'était pas
organisée et donc on n'a pas pu obtenir
les données ce qui nous aurait permis à
travers l'ia de 2,2 progressivement
assimilés quelles sont les meilleures
thérapies parce que lien nous aurait pu
aucune permettent d'obtenir ce genre
d'information or ça n'a pas été le cas
pourquoi ça n'a pas été le cas parce qu
en fait lié à travailler uniquement avec
les données qu'on lui donne et donc il
faut organiser autour de liens le
rassemblement de ces données là et en
particulier des données coded pour vous
art pour que l'ia puisse nous donner des
informations qu'on va aller plus loin là
dessus on va la regarder
pourquoi qu'est ce que c'est que l'ia
précisément et qu'est ce qui se passe
avec les données comment comment il ya
travail sur les données donc est-ce
qu'on peut aller plus loin parce que
l'ia c'est pas seulement une analyse de
données est ce qu'on peut aller plus
loin qu'une simple analyse de données
alors pour ça on va déjà faire un tour
de table un petit peu un tour d'horizon
de de la différence entre l'homme et de
l'ia puisque liés à ces intelligences
artificielles moins artificiel qui veut
qu'ils nous montrent qu' on cherche à
faire la même chose que l'intelligence
donc on a besoin de comparer
l'intelligence l'homme avec
l'intelligence artificielle ces points
de comparaison sont importants pour
qu'on puisse avoir une vision de 2
jusqu'où on peut aller avec l'ia et
c'est ce que je voudrais vous amener
c'est cette vision de jusqu'où on peut
aller les clients alors l'homme ici est
capable de percevoir le monde mais en
fait il y à aussi est capable de
percevoir le monde pourquoi les aperçus
allemande pas simplement parce qu'elle
peut apercevoir les données qu'on livre
qu'on lui donne à agir et à analyser
donc c'est une perception à travers les
données il peut par l'ia peut percevoir
des vidéos des photos des images peut
percevoir aussi du texte peut percevoir
du son donc c'est une perception dont
clairement des deux côtés on a une
intelligence de perception sur l'ia est
sûre l'homme ça c'est important de le
noter
ensuite deuxième point que je pense vous
avez tous vécu peut-être pas les plus
jeunes mais en tout cas vous laisse avec
une calculatrice une simple calculatrice
si vous voulez faire 123 x 111
le résultat vous ne connaissez pas moi
je le connais pas il pouvait pas le
calcul est par contre si vous tapez
s'assure une calculatrice vous elle
résoudre est le résultat de façon
instantanée
donc c'est ce qui montre bien que même
une calculatrice est capable de faire
des traitements et c'est tout petit
c'est aujourd'hui c'est ça coûte un euro
c'est ce sont des processus que nous
êtres humains ne savons pas bien traités
soit calculer rapidement soit encore
plus traiter des grandes données
si je vous donne un milliard de fichiers
à regarder ces 308 bible c'est juste
impossible à lire et on n'y arrive pas
par contre les ordinateurs le font très
bien et il ya le fait très bien et c
c'est une grosse qualité de l'ia ces
deux aspects là ils sont en verre ici
sont tout à fait tout à fait traiter par
l'ia et donne une gros avantage dans
beaucoup de cas au traitement
d'intelligence artificielle
c'est une différence importante avec
l'homme c'est intéressant de le noter
ici
ensuite on regarde d'autres fonctions de
l'intelligence
alors là j'en ai citer quelques unes
mais c'est penser comprendre rêver
pourquoi pas c'est une fonction de
l'intelligence mais aussi concevoir
créer inventer tous ces termes là
aujourd'hui
dans un premier temps en tout cas et je
voudrais qu'on va regarder ça est-ce
qu'il ya peut faire ce genre de choses
c'est intéressant de regarder
est-ce qu'on peut aller plus loin avec
l'ia sur ces sujets là peut-être rêver
est-ce qu est-ce qu il ya peut être
consciente jeu on regardera ça à la fin
c'est un point 1 point aussi intéressant
mais ce qui si un autre point qu'on peut
qu'on peut regarder c'est le sait la
décision déjà la décision qu'est ce que
c'est la décision c'est à partir d'un
certain nombre d'informations qu'on
connaît on réfléchit on regarde et on se
dit tiens je vais faire ça par exemple
je vais aller j'ai décidé aujourd'hui de
prendre des vacances et d'aller me
promener au bord de la mer c'est une
décision
alors est-ce qu'il ya prend des
décisions qu'en fait on va voir on va
regarder ça pourquoi lieux prend des
décisions est ce qu'elle peut prendre
des décisions alors si vous regardez un
exemple simple qui est un traitement gps
donc ce qu'on utilise tous les jours je
préfère vous donner des exemples très
simple comme ça pourquoi
et puis c'est bien voir ces aspects là
qu'est ce que fait un gps a gps il
calcule un chemin d'un point à un autre
que vous lui avez donné et ensuite il va
vous dire tourner à droite tourner à
gauche
allez tout droit le clae et à chaque
fois
qui vous dit tourner à droite ou tourner
à gauche en fait ce qui va se passer
c'est que vous allez suivre ce qui vous
propose est d'une certaine manière vous
allez passer du point a au point b avait
en suivant toutes les instructions du
gps et au final vous avez suivi toutes
ses décisions
donc vous pouvez dire oui le gps prend
effectivement une décision pour nous il
prend des décisions il n'y a pas de
différence en fait entre nous qui
prenons une carte qui choisit ce cas
choisissant d'aller à droite ou à gauche
et le gps qui nous dit ça alors bien sûr
nous en tant que personne on peut
prendre la décision de ne pas suivre le
gps mais là n'est pas le sujet le sujet
et simplement de dire oui il ya des
décisions qui sont prises par les
machines d'ailleurs l'ia en général mais
on peut même aller plus loin en parlant
par exemple d'une machine à laver la
vaisselle
donc c'est pas très intelligent pourtant
ça prend plein de décision dans son
cycle de lavage de commencer à laver de
faire tourner les tambours d'arrêter des
tambours de fer et forêts etc
il ya beaucoup de décisions qui sont
prises à l'intérieur de la machine alors
on va creuser un petit peu là je vais
être un peu technique cette fois ci pour
vous présenter un peu plus la
compréhension et est ce qu'on peut
comprendre ça c'est le sujet suivant de
de cette présentation c'est est-ce que
l'ia est capable de comprendre qu'est ce
que ça veut dire comprendre alors pour
ça je vous donne une photo d'eux d'une
petite fille tout coloré qui qui en fait
est la représentante des enfants qui
apprennent à parler et qu'ils apprennent
les concepts par exemple si vous avez
des enfants vous avez pu dire un moment
donné à votre fille ou votre fils ça
tiens regarde c'est un chien et la
première fois elle va aller toucher le
caresser etc
et puis vous allez avoir un deuxième
chien peut être un troisième a lui
montré un ou deux chiens trois chiens et
après quelles que soient les chiens elle
a reconnu que c'était un chien dont vous
voyez qu'il ya un processus
d'apprentissage comme de l'icom lire si
vous voulez mais qui qui est très rapide
avec 2,3 exemple un enfant terre
comprend déjà ce que c'est qu'un chien
alors fort de cette de cette observation
on s'est dit je me suis dit est-ce qu'on
peut essayer de reproduire en partie ce
mécanisme de compréhension dans une
machine alors pour aller plus loin je
vous présente un tout petit peu ce que
c'est que l'intelligence artificielle
basée sur les réseaux de neurones et
c'est un peu technique et je m'en excuse
des bandes avance
les réseaux de neurones sont en fait une
combinaison d'un calcul d'optimisation
de polynôme on peut le dire comme ça je
les dis tant pis polynôme sur des
équations du premier degré avec x
variable est en fait ce que fait le
réseau de neurones c'est il a un certain
nombre d'entrées ces données d'entrée il
va calculer une optimisation à partir
d'éléments d'apprentissage dont par
exemple qui va avoir 50 photos de chiens
et progressivement il va regarder toutes
ces photos là et on va lui dire tiens ça
c'est un chien ça sur un chien comme
avec les enfants
la différence avec les résonneront dès
l'enfance et qu' il faut peut-être trois
4000 5000 photos de chiens pour qu'ils
puissent comparer les chiens et les
chats par exemple où les chiens et les
autres animaux on voit qu'il ya une
différence et on peut se demander ce que
c'est moi ce que je dis est peut-être
que je m'avance là dessus c'est de dire
en vrai là le réseau de neurones est un
réseau plutôt de perception et donc il
apprend à son niveau qui est un niveau
de perception
alors nous on est à des niveaux de
compréhension qu'on apprend plus vite
donc tout ça pour vous dire que ce qu'on
voulait faire c'est essayer de coder un
système d'apprentissage à un niveau de
compréhension plutôt qu'un niveau de
perception pour ça on est parti sur un
modèle d'apprentissage qui est basée sur
la catégorisation d'intention alors
c'est un grand mot c'est un grand mot
simplement dire on est parti sur un
corpus d'environ 70 70 milles phrase
plutôt au niveau bancaire c'est à dire
je veux pas une attention c'était je
veux changer ma carte parce qu'elles
marchent plus ou bien je veux remettre
de l'argent ou pourquoi ma carte est
bloqué sa c3 intentions différentes qui
ont été exprimés qui sont exprimés dans
le corps puisque on a regardé par un
certain nombre de phrases environ 200
300 phrase par intentions et on dit on
veut lui faire apprendre ça donc vous
voyez que là on est plus sur des modèles
de de compréhension plutôt que des
modèles de perception dans le sens où ce
sont des phrases c'est quelque chose que
pour comprend un peu plus comme comme
une commune
comme une perception symbolique des
choses est pas qu une perception à
travers les yeux les oreilles et donc ce
qu'on fait ici c'est à prendre avec cet
exemple là que je vous donne des
grammaires automatiquement c'est en fait
le principe de l'apprentissage est
exactement le même
on apprend avec des grammaires et ont
fait à prendre on fabrique des
grammaires spécifiques qui vont
représenter l'ensemble de ces de ces de
ses intentions
donc le résultat je vais vous donner ici
c'est un résultat préliminaire mais je
trouve que c'est intéressant de le
présenter parce que ils vous donnent les
différences avec des systèmes existants
que que ce soit les noms ici mais c'est
ce sont les grandes les grandes
entreprises comme microsoft comme google
etc qui travaillent sur les réseaux de
neurones dont je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure donc lorsqu'on compare en vrai
et c'est simplement ça je vous montrais
ici on veut comparer une compréhension à
travers un modèle de perception vous
voyez compréhension à travers un modèle
est perçu comme vous il ya 10 de la
différence et compréhension à travers un
modèle j'irai plus de compréhension
puisqu'on est sur des grammaires sur des
modèles symbolique qu'on comprend nous
qu'on apprend à l'école tout simplement
donc c'est on parle vraiment de
compréhension ils riaient le résultat
c'est que pour tous les modèles de
perception n'est plus tôt à 90% pour les
modèles de compréhension on arrive à
monter à 100%
un peu comme les enfants voilà donc ça
c'est simple expérience que je voulais
vous présenter qui a le l'énorme énorme
avantage de peut-être démontrer un peu
la différence entre d'un apprentissage
par perception et d'apprentissage par
compréhension donc la réponse à la
question est ce que on peut causer de la
compréhension avec de l'ia la réponse
allait plutôt oui quand même
mais être à condition de travailler sur
des modèles qui sont très différents des
modèles de calcul qui sont très
différents des modèles basés uniquement
sur les réseaux de neurones alors est-ce
qu'on peut aller plus loin est-ce qu'on
peut aller plus loin sur la conception
la création et d'invention la conscience
est ce qu'on peut aller plus loin je
sais pas si si vous avez vu ça dans le
passé mais il ya des artistes peintres
qui se sont amenés à qui on qui ont été
amenés à faire des peintures très très
on dira créative il utilisait un âne il
mettait de la trempe et la queue de
l'âne dans de la peinture il faisait il
faisait en sorte que la phase de la
peinture etc
on peut considérer que c'est la création
que l'ana fait une création a fait une
peinture on peut le considérer
mais en même temps il faut pas se
tromper c'est quand même l'artiste qui a
demande qui a poussé l'anah faire ça ou
bien si on jette enfin la nature en elle
même quels que soient les événements
tout tout tout la nature et création
d'une certaine manière mais c'est une
création qui n'est pas construite par
une conscience qui sait ce qu'elle veut
faire
d'accord donc ici on va regarder si
c'est possible ou pas qu'une
intelligence artificielle en prenant un
exemple d'intelligence artificielle
plutôt très avancé et regarder et là je
vais juste vous vous poserez la question
parce que la réponse je vous en donnerai
une qui sera la mienne mais vous pouvez
vous poser cette question et vous
demandez ça et peut-être que vous
trouverez des réponses de moi je n'ai
pas trouvé ce sera tant mieux mais je
vais vous présenter ce donc c'est de cet
exemple on prend l'exemple de la voiture
autonome donc vous voulez comparer deux
choses vous pouvez vous comparer une
voiture avec un être humain dans la
voiture donc l'être humain dans la
voiture il a ses caractéristiques de de
création de conscience etc et la voiture
qui n a pas ses caractéristiques alors
ce que je peux vous présenter si vous
dire simplement dans la voiture qu'est
ce qu'il ya il y à des algorithmes des
polynômes de l'intelligence artificielle
beaucoup de traitements qui sont basées
à la fois sur sur deux liées à un réseau
de neurones et d'autres et d'autres
traitements et qui sont en global
mentent à dire des algorithmes et donc
ce que vous avez en fait dans une
voiture autonome qui fonctionne bien et
qui tourne bien c'est quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui est plus
sophistiqué mais qui reste de même
nature
ça c'est ce que je veux
je vous présente et c'est ma
compréhension des choses ça reste de
même nature qu'une machine à laver
c'est plus complexe ça fait plus de
choses ça plus de capacité de deux
calculent plus de capacité de décision
plus de capacité parce que une voiture
autonome va décider de tourner à droite
de freiner d'accélérer et c'est
énormément de décision mais ça reste une
machine à laver et donc pour moi et
c'est un peu ce que je voulais vous dire
ici c'est l'ia ne rêve pas elle ne crée
pas elle perçoit et aj ça c'est sûr
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
mais elle ne crée pas une elle ne rêve
pas ne peut pas le faire donc qui ré
requis craie qui a une conscience le
conducteur de la voiture autonome est-ce
que les deux peuvent le faire je vous ai
dit je vous ai donné ma réponse mais
c'est intéressant parce que ça donne
quand même un aspect important je pense
de la part de quelqu'un qui connaît un
peu fonctionne un peu le sujet de lias
c'est de dire l'homme a encore toute sa
place face à l'ia et je ne pense pas
qu'il faille s'inquiéter de trop de cm2
c'est de ces messages ou deux où il y
apprendrait le pouvoir un peu comme un
terminator
je ne pense pas que ce genre de chose
arrivera et d'ailleurs si je peux me
continuer à rêver parce que j'aime rêver
j'aime donner un avenir radieux à
l'intelligence artificielle et à l'homme
ce que je voudrais vous montrer voilà
c'est qu'en fait le reste c'est la
combinaison et c'est déjà le cas mais je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin et
traiter davantage ce ce système
ce système home ya comme un tout et
comme quelque chose qui va permettre
d'aller beaucoup plus loin encore plus
loin qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et on va
combiner comme vous voyez ici la
capacité de l'iaa à traiter de grands
doutes de grands de grandes données et à
calculer rapidement les choses
combiné à cette perception est cette
décision et on va combiner avec l'homme
qui lui même est capable de penser qu'on
prend à rêver concevoir créer inventer
toutes ces choses qui font l'innovation
qui font la grandeur de l'homme et qui
font que l'homme est capable de se
dépasser à chaque instant je pense que
c'est ça combiné à l'ia qui peut nous
amener beaucoup plus loin et beaucoup
plus haut donc je pense que c'est c'est
un message c'est ce message là je
voulais vous montre vous passer à
travers une analyse de l'ia ce qu'on
peut vraiment aller plus loin donc en
conclusion l'iar est une combinaison de
polynôme une machine à laver rien de
plus une machine red est très complexe
et jeu il faut garder je pense que c'est
même presque opérationnel de garder
cette vision de l'ia pour faire pour
faire ce travail de combinaison entre
l'homme il y a c'est vraiment important
de voir cette vision comme ça par
ailleurs mon message aussi ses clients
n'est pas limitée aux réseaux de
neurones même si aujourd'hui c'est très
prégnant dans dans la science il ya
d'autres façons de faire de l'ia comme
je voulais montrer tout à l'heure qui
sont parfois plus être plus adapté qui
peut-être sans la préfiguration d'une ia
qui comprend davantage de choses ça
c'est très intéressant
et enfin comme je voulais dit la
meilleure combinaison ça reste quand
même celle de l'homme et de l'ia et
c'est mon message qui à la fois un
message je pense rationnel est aussi un
message d'espoir j'espère vraiment et je
pense réellement que c'est cette voie là
qu'il faut qu'on suive dans le futur
voilà je vous remercie beaucoup pour
cette présentation j'espère que elle a
pu vous ouvrir d'autres
d'autres voies et d'autres façons de
penser et peut-être vous allez créer des
start up et inventait des choses avec de
l'ia mais en pensant que vous êtes aux
contrôles et aux manettes de ce que vous
allez créer voilà merci beaucoup